proudly displaying their we love
necrophilia badges more far and beauty
pie proudly present their horrible
walkthrough of Dead Island kick him kick
him back okay
huh that do our kick booty Charaka
he's dead no problem are you some fasten
some [ __ ] I don't so we're going to get
fuel from oh this is a gas station how
much genius I figure that out myself so
I think it's in Polish guy no yes I am
it was ugly as [ __ ] okay you are I'll
even if I can open open open open open
open open or what trash no I want in
trash more Irish oh secret location but
I want you to trash oh wait look look
like how much genius I can jump behind
this can I jump on the roof
can i no no wait but I'm I'm inside the
shop really getting getting good is
getting what okay
empty I got an empty canister yeah what
the [ __ ] am I going to do with that I
found a little fire weapon do you are
you level 5 no it would have been
awesome
umm maybe um I know to talk to this guy
sorry
the pumps ain't working but how did you
go inside is another way in
they chose the route the door I work
genius right of course and take some
canisters with okay yeah
we we need to get mr. ed hey dude you
dude you can't use mr. ed we need to
take canisters with us use mr. ed this
miss is mr. pink Akane
okay yeah sure it's okay so on the roof
you said something about the room yes
how the [ __ ] are we going to get the
canister up - well you I don't know
shake the room chatter there's nothing
here except two boxes
oh oh oh yeah we need one box each
weight are thrown down for you what nice
man you were there like why would I need
about I don't know you said you wanted
something I was like I didn't go I'm
just being nice
wait uh I also read that quest like
quest not sure just allottee bring
approval to grade station Bundaberg turn
on the gas pumps okay oh and what did
you say the room let's here's a gas
cannon canister but he said it's yeah
exactly but let's pull it back what oh
you are here please tell you here oh
there's 11 4 here it go to roof and get
down here because he's going for me he
won't see you Livesey I'm coming oh
there's two of them
I'm so gonna die in here no it's okay hi
hey I will have don't wear a shovel I
need that shovel I need it oh crap I'm
gonna die oh [ __ ]
now I'm dead No
trying to kick it on that oh [ __ ] now
I'm dead no I'm not dead I'm not dead
I'm lying I'm dead I'm back here ah ah
hey they're more fancy but yeah I'm just
going to see if I can find some some
help
God that guy is a [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] yes like I can I can drive the
car can you come with the car and pick
me out but you're almost dead - wait how
couldn't you teleport I don't understand
I am your strength what are you doing
I stopped do you know what do you know
how much problem I have in I don't care
you read I need you every to die I did
know how you can know this you don't
love me I am camera footage proving but
you left me to die let's collab oh no I
died [ __ ] you answer end let's go let's
go let's go but but seriously we need to
kill this guy to actually progress it
really got here now we can do it it's
okay well just have to I had like no
health when I came at him
oh crap mr. red is Fred mr. Brett oh
yeah we have a show show quickly we
should have picked up the show are you
back in the eye are you dead or why I
don't understand
no I'm not dead go up the roof but I'm
like so far away I spawned in the what
yeah it's gone way back what I don't
know why either but they wanted to spawn
me there so I have to run for a while
running super running I have to save
more fart oh [ __ ] I see something I see
something that is going to help me and
think oh no I need to kill I'm not
effective where is he I don't know dude
he has so much huff and I have so much
and Ibarra but I'm behind the course he
come get me uh wait I'm coming don't
worry son I'm trying to like at least at
least get a swing on him before he gets
a swing on me mm-hmm-hmm didn't make a
move and he's like oh I like and you're
like yeah I like it you you should be to
get it
oh [ __ ] okay one more hit and I'm down I
hear him he sounds really sexy he has
about 15% of how you can do it oh but
more fun oh no no no I did not
did you said that like five times let's
say oh I died alright happy nothing it's
a skill [ __ ] actually it's a UH a
headshot Oh boom Shakalaka you don't
have a [ __ ] edit or your [ __ ] I'm so
happy I killed it and this core is
actually drivable again I don't want to
walk back I got where are you I'm inside
the garage wait wait wait wait wait wait
I'm coming to pick you up
are you kidding me I'm here you
I want to punch you I ran all this way
and that now you're like oh wait I can't
figure I mean I yes tonight right now
what oh I it's on that side and I kill
them boss ah thank you
my it's a cleansing anguish hey push the
button where what are you doing we're on
the left side there's a red button it's
a chaos' this sit here okay Wow on your
left you see a red ah guys I said why I
think that's exactly yep there we go
but I'll sit in the back it's cool oh
that doesn't work right now we need to
wait on the car but hey we can't trash
this car because this car I think we're
going to whether it's all out there
zombies they're zombies they're zombies
yeah but there's always a there you go
okay sure sure yeah okay but we are
going to fill up the canisters load them
up on the car and bring it back to the
station
mmm-hmm so let's not trash the car
nah-ah die [ __ ] trash told them the car
okay I guess so we need to we need the
canisters or what yeah there's again I
get that canister mr. ken no no and then
we just go here and do something window
or what oh yeah there there where where
how do you do that oh there we go
oh you took mine yeah sure that's fine
oh they will come when we do that I
think refill the canister hold F I'm
holding don't worry I'll do everything
in the you just watch and I'll do
everything there we go and the gas too
Mike
oh you're supposed to protect me I do my
best
it's okay I can throw the canister is
that a failed no yeah it's Phil and I'm
oh you're just quick to give they're
here weary I think we need more than one
yeah we need all of them right
I can't pick them up so I think there's
ah yes what this is driving [ __ ] yeah
but it's yeah at me that's right
so we're driving on this side of
interchange angle no oh I can jump out
while you're driving it friendly perfect
where are you at um you can go let's go
I'm sitting here don't worry oh okay if
you have a shotgun or something like
that I would have been awesome I hope
I'm going to drive over a couple of
zombies do it I'm here with mr. Kenneth
sir don't worry oh Allah I love how the
game is progressing now we are actually
getting a car now we I'm really careful
about this car axes you better yeah I
can tell you really casual you're
driving over everything you can get so
many zombies with is right
dude bang don't drive in there ah
are you missing dude yeah no try to miss
a nice action
oh [ __ ] yeah this is the way and then we
but I'm confused
oh ah we're mm-hmm let's bring canister
to the mother for Indian wants canister
nice going with the campus hey what am i
doing okay I got it okay
bring it to the guy with all the corpses
so you need corpses and a fuel tank
I understand hey thank you gutsy oh this
is going to be kicker yeah I'm going to
light a cigarette
mm-hmm you do that la la la hey want
I saw a goddess yeah I want ice cream as
well I need help can you get that when
you're in here so we need to speak with
Felix what Felix really my fingers name
is Freddy
no Alex Here I am you [ __ ] my
dominate okay we need to find dad those
are totally something I understand you
don't want pairs of anything useful why
the Charley's God oh don't forget to
repair not all you all your weapons but
it's so expensive no it's not yes do you
think it's sixpence
yes definitely but yeah guess it's
driving
but we're not driving that's very let's
go I'm pop but we haven't spoken to
let's go let's go okay I'm kidding I'm
going to find Dominic wait somebody help
me with this bloody door won't take a
second hey it's remember me it looks
beautiful
yeah oh I got a question I'm just going
to break the door okay I guess Domon
Dominic is inside there bloody Health
Service
oh it's zombie I want to kill her ah
Anja killer killer killer a dares to
wait oh oh damn about 9:00 everybody oh
hello she's the fun pain killers thank
you you lose everything no nothing no
what's with the music it's really
annoying okay so that was a pretty quick
level ah yeah okay I keep going with the
Furious thingy
killing and with with throwing weight he
has another question find an ambulance
or a lifetime vehicle to bring the
paramedic back to the tower that would
be awesome we actually know where there
is it's up the road I don't remember you
really
what is this I find another ending party
oh you did a tuna look let's go to the
engine guy and see if that's enough okay
the sooner you find what I need
the sooner you get behind the wheel I
love our energy drinks this year I goes
to go to em and press F and you just
give him all the engine parts this guy
yeah I can I can I can I can't click it
I'm drying ah I know where we go away
yeah sure you drive you all this dry you
can drive next time no I don't wanna I
don't wanna not it's ok I don't want to
die but it's ok
oh shoot that's ok I don't know why it
didn't die away
wow he's persistent there we go that is
a lot of damage and there is a paramedic
up here yeah you're right so take care
of that [ __ ] and I'll just drive over
them I got your back
yeah yeah thank you I think I crushed it
okay so car what yeah bag a bag shake
all right better I did it I took it I
would don't worry I got it I got it but
I want that yeah tonight lock-picking
stuff requires lockpick yeah we need to
acquire more skill set really hope to
turn with this week really so I wait for
many more fire yes I'm just trying to
I'm just trying to okay I'm sitting in
the back so you can go oh wait don't go
no more fire top but wait I mean what
the [ __ ] just happened okay let's go I
got the parts ticket yay why is there
skulls on the map what does that mean I
think those are I don't know
you know not know how could i I don't
know
feels like I'm in a 70s movie yeah
exactly
hey okay next time is your time to drive
that's for sure
yeah that's gonna be interesting oh now
I can't give him the car part this [ __ ]
what do you want now let's go to the
paramedic guy inside here huh huh so
give him the stuff he needed and it's
very good in here
I'm oh s engine what Oh No yes
oh it's inside here oh it's a it's a
clinic so I've saved a lot of lives mate
maybe even to you
boom I got a sickle oh damn fire we
leveled up let's see what we can get I
have a freaking sick go huh she killed
sickle was it yeah I read that right I
never mind
how do I put it on oh there we go
screech one two three four five one two
three four five yes look at this look at
this it's awesome it's beautiful I want
to go down to make sure I love how I
lose his bag of money right in front of
them touch day so we can heal at this
guy oh my god what the [ __ ] is you what
did I also get one of those yeah
probably
it's beautiful no I didn't haha of
course of course
so and now Dominic Dominic we need to
find Garmin a scourge came from outer
space Dominic Dominic
yeah isn't isn't oh yeah yeah Dominic so
are you upset no I'm not upstairs I'm
actually
yup start shaking for Dominic downstairs
okay I'm shaking Dominic for Dominic
upstairs second Dominic Dominic oh yeah
don't go Dominika keep you are you sure
yeah yeah I found domine / Dominic this
piece of [ __ ] in tennis okay it's the
same question like like I guess we have
to do how can I so you know we need to
go and get our amplifier from the well
do you have the GPS otherwise
meaningless for you to drive I have in
your business a prom
don't you dare take my spot out like why
do you it's confusing why are you in the
car yeah okay
hey yeah yeah I'm trying so I don't have
all yeah I can't no I can't like sit
back relax enjoy dear oh oh oh yeah if
we lose this chord you know how rare
cars are in this game not but but it's
okay I'm a good driver don't worry I got
this is no problem
Thomas